on ne rit plus on rit plus comme avant
écoutez en venant ici j'ai vu dans la
rue j'ai vu ce soir un type qui veut un
type choir et ça ne m'a pas fait rire
j'écoutais avant quand je voyais voir un
type jeunesse pas fait et là si tout
juste s'il fut pas lui dire ce que vous
vous êtes fait mal il faut dire qu'il
avait mal sûr ils avaient de quoi parce
que maintenant les gens soient plus voir
quand tu joues à espoo triste
le joueur et sa formule des branches
sans pouvoir ils s'imaginent que ce soir
c'est déchoir soir n'est pas déchoir
donc qui a chuté très déçu à condition
qu'ils soient bien commencé mon père ou
que tu fous un choix bien ce commentaire
les chéris s'appuie chan il savait ce
que c'était que de choir il a été aux
bus de choir de soirée dans un chic
souls un chapiteau il avait pas mal vu
dans la chute dans la sciure et il y
aurait voulu que je sois mieux que lui
partout le team faisait soirs comme ça
de ses genoux il m'incitait à choir les
chemins fois mon soudan ainsi sur
qu'est-ce qu'il a une toile
non seulement il faisait choir chez moi
mais il m'en voyez choir chez les autres
et on s'est parfois mal fait et notre
nom soit mieux chez soi même parce qu'on
soit sans retenue on se croit parfois
donné que c'est évidemment le choix font
mettre des gants permettez que je sois
ici boom
ou bien préférer bon je sois labeaume
alors quand on a toujours vu dans la
chute dans la sueur et que soudainement
il faut se parfaire le tapis on jouera
pas dans son élément
onze fois plus long que son haut rang
alors réflexion où il manque de savoir
choix vous avez vu qu'aux me lâcher ma
chère
oui parce que dans un certain milieu
parce que dans un certain milieu choir
ça s'apprend et les cours du soir
j'y suis allé vous apprennent à choir en
trois soirs alors vous avez le pressoir
d'ailleurs ces instants qui précèdent le
moment de leur choix
bon alors vous avez le choix romandie
blanche mais on peut pas le choix bon et
une fois je suis vous avez l'après choix
pour moi j'ai eu des après choir
difficile parce que oui même plus
m'asseoir
alors comme au bout de trois choix
enchaîné toujours pas fait je deviens
choir j'ai laissé tomber
alors mon père en sortant mon père me
dit médias les choix un peu devant moi
que je vois aux tournées sur le plan
choir bon
enfin je n'étais pas chaud en fait le
choix c'est pas que tu sois mal mais tu
choix raid est dix fois ce soit comme ça
les regarde à chaque fois et je vois
comme le il touchera bien parce qu'un
chat un chat un chat ses choix je suis
anti mafia aussi ses formes est moins
bien qu'un achat ah si un jour j'ai vu
un chat ou un chien un chien ou un shu
fu un petit chouchou qui co après une
poule qui faisait croire d'un perchoir
je suis de tout un concours de
circonstances en faire trop non c'est à
dire que la poule avez vu ce soir un
mouchoir d'un séchoir à forest avait
chuté en fin de l été chercher alors le
chiot voyons là pour ce soir c'est elle
en cherche à poursuivre les achats pour
sur sa poursuite
alors attendez le plus souhaité la chute
est alors le chu a su un choix
journaleux le chat sur le chiot c est
bien mais bel et bien le chouchou a
moins bien je sus que le chercheur
chichis